90% of people tend to just fully panic a
lot of crashes there's a ton of concern
I think I'm just as nervous
what's up I'm Emily and I really like
cars as a kid I used to play with cars
all the time in any shape and form
whether that was a Barbie car and RC car
Hot Wheels golf carts go-karts driving
my dad's car around in the yard
all of it and I think it pretty much
goes without saying that the coolest
thing you could ever drive is a monster
drunk so when Monster Jam reached out to
BuzzFeed to see if anyone wanted to
learn how to drive a monster truck I
obviously kept very calm and cool and
professional so my friend Zach was like
is anyone interested in doing a video on
the Monster Jam and then I was like oh
my god I love Monster Jam and then my
friend Megan was all approaced you and
then I followed up and I was like dude
let me drive the trucks and then
definitely I actually think so yeah it
was like oh my god yes so since I've
certainly never driven a Monster Jam
truck before it the first step was to
talk to some people who have
I don't know to drive one of these
things yeah this is like not a training
truck so this thing's like 100% like
ready to rip
have you ever drove anything like
high-performance I Drive a 2006 Thailand
TC yeah I think she's got 160 horsepower
yeah I was about to say that's probably
bout 12 of those take about 12 those
motors seen has 1500 horsepower 12,000
pounds so your way in left-field
there's a ton of concern that - throwing
I don't even know how to explain your
your level into a professional level
vehicle what should I be wearing about
90% of people tend to just fully panic
and normally the panic mode is to hit
the throttle water but that's not a good
idea I can't imagine why listen there's
no lag it's instant when you hit the
pedal it's gone
okay so just to give you okay there's a
lot of a lot of mistakes that are made
and a lot of crashes cuz I can guarantee
you go to step in that truck your hands
are gonna start trembling and shaking
when I pull out on the track I have no
plan right I'm just gonna go crazy I'm
not stopping until the truck stop and I
hope like heck you know the trucks tore
up but I'm not right no Monday morning
when you roll out of bed you're like man
I felt like I just got in the car crash
because you did yeah yeah we kind of
shouldn't be doing what we're doing with
this motor but we're gonna make an
exception yeah there's a gas and brake
in a steering wheel which is all sounds
horrible but then there's an ignition
switch start button fans so multiple
fans water Q laters
on a few of our steers we simply touch
the top on a shifter at that time you'll
figure it out I can explain it to you
all day how to drive a monster Jam truck
but until you do it nothing it's just
like in one ear out the other
uh-huh I mean you can't do anything
worse than what we do that's true and if
I did that today that I've done
something yeah we'll probably never have
you bet I'm excited now I guess we're
just gonna get the suit on and then
we'll be driving so you're gonna be in a
fully flame-resistant suit you're gonna
have the same neck restraint systems
that we run in the trucks same helmets
that we weren't in trucks fire resistant
gloves shoes and ready my whole life I
remember seeing like Monster Jam for
shalls' and being like I want to go my
parents are like in 2018
and 2018 my twin brother died and it was
really terrible for a a while I kind of
thought my life was over and nothing
really made sense or mattered anymore
and I went home for a while to be with
my family and when I came back I was all
by myself and like this new way and I
didn't know what I was gonna do or how
my life was gonna be now when I got back
I went on Facebook as you do and I saw
an ad for Monster Jam triple threat
something I always wanted to go to and
never did as a kid kind of weirdly
resurfaced in my life when I needed it
the most
and so I organized a huge group of my
friends to go and rocked
monster Jim was really the first thing
that I did after my brother died that
like really allowed me to just have fun
and kind of forget about my life for a
second and how sad I was but I didn't
tell anyone at Monster Jam that one of
them that thing I was cruel
[Music]
crash rollover and have even heated on
all four wheels she's in the truck I'm
gonna get her the rest of the way
strapped in and we're gonna go through
her first startup process and then after
that I'm getting the heck out of here
and we're gonna turn her loose on this
this is the start button and in this is
the ignition button
this thing is a absolute lifesaver
power on
[Music]
that was insane I'm not gonna lie it was
very impressive you picked up on
everything super fast like the shifting
the starting technique the rear steer
like normally there's always rookie
mistakes on each one of those yeah she
picked up on the right away I couldn't
believe that we like we have drivers
that weren't that good at the beginning
now that are really good so she like was
awesome fast like very impressive
well thank you so much yeah this is like
the best day of my yeah so to sum they
might just be big dumb trucks to me
being able to drive one of these things
that just brought me so much joy and
happiness when I was in the darkest
moment of my life
just really means that's so much so much
more I'm the queen of Monster Jam baby
and in life and everyone's life there
might be times when you feel like you
may never be able to have a single ounce
of fun again and it's times like that
when we really need things like Monster
Jam
so I hope that you find your master
[Music]
[Music]